cute give me something hashtag
cops-and-robbers
yeah
the owners alleged out here when he
fights ours are packed lines out the
doors to watch Ricky ain't the champ
everybody sees on TV I know who really
is widespread violence has the city on
edge back where you came from
we're out of do it whether it's the own
responsible or not people will
definitely be coming for some payback we
got to be careful what do you say we
take down a suspect everybody in my
circle is loyal someone set you up
[Music]
I'm married married there are certain
mistakes that you can make in life that
you can't come back from I don't know if
I was ever really in love with him if
you're watching I said important people
have important secrets
I need those videos oh my god
I'm gonna find out who did this whatever
it takes I'll settle for justice
well what are you gonna do I'll do what
any reasonably trained detective would
do with a bag of peas on her face at a
time like this somehow I feel like this
involves me
[Music]
you